[MUSIC PLAYING]
NEEVE NIKOO: Hello, everyone.
I'm Neeve Nikoo,
and this is Geir.
We're here today to
talk about FuboTV
and how they've become a great
streaming provider in under 24
months with Google Cloud.
So just little more background--
I'm a customer engineer
with Google Cloud
in New York in the Media
and Entertainment Division.
So we're partnering with media
and entertainment clients.
I come from doing this
in the on-premise world
and then moving to Cloud,
so I have a good background
in this space.
I don't know if--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Oh, and
I'm the CTO of FuboTV.
I come to this from an
advertising background
and a video background.
If you remember a company called
Juiced some number of years
ago, we're trying
something similar.
NEEVE NIKOO: So just
a quick agenda today--
we're going to go a little
bit into video distribution,
different problems
and considerations
that we see in the market today.
Then we'll talk about Google
Cloud's offerings to that.
There's a couple of
different solution pathways
that we can go.
And then we'll talk about
Fubo and their case study
and their approach
to streaming, and go
into how they were successful,
what their architecture is,
best practices, and talk
about their timelines
to current date, and
then some exciting stuff
that they're going to be doing
this year and moving forward.
So why is live
video so difficult?
How many people
here have watched
any type of video stream,
and it's been buffering,
and you've waited on
either a phone, a browser--
yeah.
I would say everyone, right?
So why is--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: And for those
that haven't, have you just not
looked at video on the internet?
NEEVE NIKOO: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
So this is a really hard
problem to solve, actually,
and there's a lot of
things to consider.
So just real quick, to level
set and get a good picture
of what's going on--
so with live video
distribution, there's
these different
components that you have.
So first you have
to actually acquire
all of your different signals.
So this can be via
satellite, camera, fiber.
There's many different
ways to do so.
Then you're going to take that
into an MPEG transport stream,
and you're going to do
a bunch of processing--
encoding, transcoding, having
your digital rights management,
logos that are needed,
and get the video stream
ready to actually deliver.
Then, now, how do I actually
deliver this globally?
So I need to partner
with many CDN providers
to then get and distribute
this to all the different types
of devices.
So this is a really,
really, really, really--
I'll just keep saying
that-- high level
of the end-to-end video
distribution workflow.
We'll go into more detail
and technical depth,
but I just wanted
to set the stage.
So what are all the
different things
that we have to consider?
So this has been an
industry that's been around
for quite a number of years--
broadcast.
This has been done
via satellite,
where I have a set, fixed
amount of bandwidth,
and it's just been new protocols
that have come out every 5,
10 years or so that's
basically compressed the data.
So how much data can I fit
with a fixed bandwidth rate?
Now there's many
different devices.
So that brings a bunch
of different problems.
And when I'm sending
video over the internet,
I have to account for all
the different devices,
the different video formats that
are needed based on the device
that I have for the
picture quality.
And in that workflow,
in order to do that,
there's so many
different partners
that you're going to have
to actually go through with.
So in Fubo's case,
they have to acquire
all these different
types of content
from many different providers.
So there's CBS.
There's Fox.
There's all the
different sports streams.
And that's just on
the content part,
not even including who
they choose to partner
with on the video processing
side, the CDN side, et cetera.
So there's many different parts
and many different companies
that are in the
entire workflow that
can really make this a pretty
tough problem to actually
solve.
And then not to say how
much bandwidth there is--
so there's different bandwidth
at each part in that workflow.
And then, at the end device, I
can have really poor internet
because I'm a cheap guy.
I only have 20
megabits per second.
How am I going to get
high-quality video compared
to somebody who's paying
for the one gigabit line?
So there's many, many
different problems that we see.
And then the coverage
area globally--
so there's going to be
people where there's maybe
not infrastructure that
is really best served
in that area.
So how can I serve
someone in the middle
of nowhere versus a
large metropolitan city?
So these are all
different things
that we have to consider
when distributing live video.
So where can Google help?
So we have the
largest cloud network.
I had to show the
beautiful scaled slide
that you've probably seen in 15
other different presentations.
But in all seriousness, we
have an extremely impressive
network, over 100
points of presence,
and we really think this can
help with scaling large video.
We have many different
applications that I'm sure
we all use, and so we really
think we help with scale,
especially with live
video distribution.
So there's a couple
different solution pathways
that you can go when trying to
solve the problem of live video
distribution.
So the spectrum is
infrastructure as a service--
you see it on the
left-hand side--
all the way to
software as a service.
So we've seen multiple clients
and partners of ours do both.
It just depends where you want
to turn the different knobs.
So on the right-hand
side, we have
products we call Anvato, which
is our video processing suite.
We've seen NBC and
CBS use this before.
And then on the left, we
see different partners
such as Fubo who use our
infrastructure as a service
solution set, so using
different things like GKE,
Compute Engine, and other GCP
offerings that we've seen.
So it just depends.
Infrastructure as a service
gives you the most flexibility
in your deployment, and you can
really control different parts
in the video
distribution workflow,
whereas software as a service
gives you what you need,
but you have a little
bit less control on that.
And we see this with a
bunch of Cloud offerings
today, with serverless and
then also Compute Engine.
So there's just
different methodologies
that you can do so,
and I think that's what
makes Cloud a really
unique and fun place to be.
We give you the
tool sets, and you
can choose what makes
the most sense for you
in your business and
your application.
So I've kind of set
the stage talking
about what the problem
is, different things
that you have to consider
throughout the video
distribution workflow, and
the different offerings we
think that GCP can help with.
Now I'm going to
hand it over to Geir
to talk about Fubo, their
journey on GCP, and the reason
that they chose the
specific architecture
and different components
that they did.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: This
thing is getting annoying.
Thank you.
NEEVE NIKOO: Do you want me
to click the slides on here?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Sorry?
NEEVE NIKOO: Do you want me to
click the slides, or you go it?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: No, I
can click the slides.
NEEVE NIKOO: All right.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: If you can--
if you want to
click the slides--
NEEVE NIKOO: No, it's up--
I'm flexible.
GEIR MAGNUSSON:
So how many of you
are cord cutters that get
your TV consumption not
from your bandwidth provider?
All right, so some
number of you.
Marketing always hates when I
do this, but how many of you
are Fubo customers?
All right.
Great.
Thank you.
NEEVE NIKOO: I'm one, too.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: I just look at
this as a tremendous potential
for our business.
So Fubo is a OTT
streaming service.
We are sports-focused.
We call ourselves the
world's only sports-focused.
It really comes from our
origin as a provider that
was delivering for soccer, and I
think the name came from a riff
on football.
What we do is we deliver both
live television and VOD to you.
And when we say live
television, these
are the channels that you would
get from any other provider--
Fox, Turner, et cetera, sports
stations like BN Sports.
You'll get NBCSN, NBC stations.
We have locals, so just your
local television affiliates
for Fox, NBC.
We also have regional
sports nets, so--
I don't know--
NESN in Boston or SNY in New
York for your local sports.
And it's available on
pretty much anything
that you would
want to show it on.
We are trying to
make it a really
great in-home experience,
so you can get it
to your smart TV or your
various TV-connected devices
like an Apple TV or Fire TV.
But you can also
get it on the web.
You can also get it
on mobile devices,
pretty much anywhere
you want to be
as long as there's bandwidth.
So a little bit
of our backstory--
we'll get into some
technical things in a moment.
The original product vision
was to aggregate VODs
for professional football clubs,
or teams, as they're called.
NEEVE NIKOO: That's soccer
for anyone who is American.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Soccer.
Yeah, sorry.
It's this foreign sport
that's really popular.
NEEVE NIKOO: Ha.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: What
the clubs were doing is,
on their website, they
would have content specific
to their teams.
So you go to Everton and you can
see game replays, highlights,
interviews, backstory
kind of stuff.
But a lot of soccer fans
like multiple teams.
So what Fubo was trying to
do was bring it all together
in one place where you can get
this content for all of soccer.
And it didn't quite
work because--
at least in a market sense--
sports fans like live sports.
Right?
Anybody here who
is a sports fan?
Do you tend to want
to watch it live,
or are you willing to record
it and watch it next week?
Live, right?
So Fubo had to bring
in live streaming.
And while VOD is fairly
straightforward--
because you can get the
asset ahead of time,
you can transcode it,
prepare it, quality control
and make sure it's a good
experience for the consumer,
and then put it out in
your distribution system--
live is a real-time thing.
Right?
It's being broadcast.
And when I say live, I'll also
use linear interchangeably.
For me, live is
actually true live,
when people are out on
the field doing something
or like an awards show or
something where it's actually
happening in real time.
Linear is just the
general idea that we
have these streams
being broadcast at us,
and they need to be delivered as
close to real time as possible.
And it cannot be in real time.
There's latency.
It's just physics and
architecture forces.
But adding this linear stream
became a really big change
for the business,
both technically
and as well from the
perspective of the business.
And I'll give a little bit of
background on the business.
We're a cable company.
We're no different in
some ways than whoever
your cable provider is.
We have to license the content
from the content owners--
Fox, Hallmark, whoever.
And we use that
same business model
that the cable
companies do, which
is, we have to pay on a per
subscriber basis, not what's
viewed.
But if we have a quarter
million subscribers,
we will pay 250,000 times
whatever the per subscriber
fee is.
And this makes a pretty tough
business because a lot of money
goes into purchasing the content
or licensing the content.
In fact, in our business,
we don't quite even
break even on subscriber fees.
Subscriber fees plus
a little bit more
are given all to
the content owners.
And our business is
about making it up
from advertising and
other content upsells.
On the technology side--
and this is where we're
going to go into in a moment.
Adding linear, it was a
really big difference.
The plane is always in the air.
You can never stop.
You can never pause.
It just has to work.
And we're competing
with the system that
has over 70 years of development
behind it and is fairly stable.
When you turn on your television
on a legacy distribution
system, it works.
And it works really well.
And for us to be
successful, we have
to deliver that kind
of consumer experience
without owning the
infrastructure,
network path to the user,
and it's a bit of a trick.
Apparently my slide
changed itself.
So why is this hard?
I think it's because
we're all figuring it out.
Certainly the content
owners, our partners,
are figuring it out.
We are a different kind of place
for content to be pushed to.
We have different requirements.
We're in different places.
We don't have satellite
downlink infrastructure.
We don't have broadcast centers.
We are in the cloud.
Single acquisition
partners are people
who specialize in transport,
of getting it from the content
partner to the cloud.
They are also figuring it
out because, again, it's
a new thing to
get into the cloud
and to integrate with
these other parties.
Our Cloud partners
are figuring it out.
We do a kind of
workload that isn't very
common in cloud environments.
Some people think
it's a little crazy
to do in a cloud environment
with the variability
in multitenancy that
you're going to run into,
but we make it work.
CDN partners-- same thing.
We're certainly figuring it out.
And then consumers also
are part of the chain.
They are effectively part
of the distribution system
in that their in-home networks
are part of the delivery path.
The different kinds
of devices that they
would need to be able to
have a good OTT experience
is also something new to them.
We'll get to technical
stuff in a moment.
Our timeline is, we were
founded in 2015, entirely
soccer-focused.
We talked about how we went
to VOD, adding a linear,
but that really wasn't
a success in the market
either because any sport
is limited in terms of time
and limited in
terms of interest.
You have your season--
baseball season, I
guess, which seems
to go on forever, like hockey.
But football season's in
the fall, early winter.
Soccer season is limited.
So what we needed
to do is to make it
something that you would
subscribe to and keep all year
round.
We had to have other content.
NEEVE NIKOO: The
slide keeps changing.
I don't know why.
But it--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: If I
just keep jumping--
NEEVE NIKOO: Ha.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: So
we added Fox, NBC.
We added CBS-- so now,
starting to produce
a content package that's
really for the whole family.
We launched advanced DVR, which
is a table stakes if you're
going to have an OTT service,
hit 100,000 subscribers
by the end of 2017,
really focused now
on building a business out of
it by adding server-side ad
insertion, which is
the main monetization
driver for the business.
What we do is, on every
stream that's coming
to every single user, they're
all individual streams,
and we're able to insert
advertising on a per user,
per stream basis.
We'll talk about that
a little bit later.
Apparently, it's a big event
that I joined the place,
but I've been there
for about a year.
We were the first to
do 4K streaming OTT,
and we did it with the World
Cup, which was last year.
That's a large event played
mostly by foreigners-- soccer.
How many people are soccer fans?
OK.
So you knew what
the World Cup was.
NEEVE NIKOO:
Football and soccer--
we're going to interchange that.
Just-- we're not
confusing anyone, so--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: We have
an international strategy.
We launched into
Spain, and then we
keep adding new
content to the package.
So how many people know
how streaming really works?
It's not a continuous stream
of bits being sent at you.
It is really a
series of files that
are just being loaded over,
and buffered, and then played
at you.
So I'm going to give
this as a background,
talking about something
called HTTP live streaming.
It's a fairly simple
protocol, some
would argue one that should
never have made it out
of the design room.
But the way it works
is, you have a source.
Usually it's a pretty fat
source, 30 megabits a second,
50 megabits a second,
depending on the quality of it.
It is encoded.
And what that means is we take
that sort of mezzanine feed
and we turn it into
multiple bit rates.
So there may be a 10 megabit
stream, a 7, a 5, a 3, 1, 750K,
whatever you choose to do.
It's the variant
ladder, it's called.
And the reason why you do that
is, it allows the player to,
based on the trouble it's
having loading content,
switch to different bit rates to
keep continuity of the stream.
You're going to lose quality
as the bit rate goes down,
but you at least
get the experience.
Now, what encoding
is doing, it's
creating little files
that are called manifests.
It's a text file that is
a list of the next series
of video segments that are
to be played by the player.
And then video segments
are just chunks of video
that are being produced and
then dropped into storage.
So these would be, say,
S3 buckets somewhere.
Or I guess I misspelled--
NEEVE NIKOO: You spelled
that wrong, actually.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: I
misspelled that.
Right.
It's actually--
NEEVE NIKOO: It's spelled GCS.
So--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: GCS.
NEEVE NIKOO: But
that's all right.
That's fine.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: So what
the player is doing
is the player's going
to ask for a manifest.
It'll say, give me the next
manifest, takes the manifest,
and then starts loading
the video segments.
And when it has enough of
them, it'll start the playback.
But then it keeps
this process going
while the video's playing,
asking for the next manifest.
Every four seconds, it
asks for a manifest.
And these manifests
keep getting updated
as new chunks are being
created off the encoder,
and playback occurs.
So this is fundamentally
how HLS works.
And DASH is very similar.
It's a different standard,
but it's basically--
give me a list of things
to do, start playing it,
keep fetching, keep giving
me the list, and so on.
NEEVE NIKOO: Apple thanks
you for your explanation.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Yeah,
so it's a call out to--
I feel like I should be selling
something here on the floor,
anyway.
NEEVE NIKOO: Ha.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: So the
obligatory "how this maps
into Google services" slide--
ingestion is on the
networking infrastructure.
Google has an excellent
So we bring a lot of streams
right into us that way.
We do the encoding
or the transcoding
using Google Compute.
We are dropping into
multiple storages
for redundancy,
multiple regions.
And then a delivery
network such as Google CDN
is used to front the
origins, and the devices
pull in the way we just
described with the HLS lesson.
Now, what we do is a
little more complicated
than the previous slide.
There's a couple
of pieces of this.
We've got third-party inputs.
That would be-- content
is the biggest one.
And there's some content
providers up there.
We get Metadata because,
as part of any television,
you want to have a guide, like
an electronic program guide.
So we need to get
that information,
and that comes from a
company called Gracenote.
Tribune Media Services
is the subsidiary.
There's other kinds of data
sources that can come in.
And then there's
third-party services
that we use for mainly noncore
things, such as subscription
management and payments.
More on that in a sec.
Then inside this big gray
box is really what we do.
If you can think
of-- the platform
divides into a couple of pieces.
There's video
management and delivery.
There is program, data,
and discovery, and then--
program, comma, data,
and discovery-- and then
user and subscription management
are the three big chunks.
And then there's, finally,
the client applications
that we also build.
So we build apps for
mobile, for web, obviously.
And then we're
building smart TV apps.
Samsung is about to be released
in Beta in the next couple
of weeks, and then Apple TV--
the pucks, as I call them--
Apple TV, Roku, the
sticks, Fire TV--
whatever.
What we're doing is actually
a lot more complicated
than the original HLS slide
for a bunch of reasons.
First of all, we
have permissioning
and licensing to worry about.
And not only is
it, are you allowed
to access content at all but
is, very specifically, what
content?
And a lot of this is
based on where you are.
The two things that
fold into this,
or the primary thing
that folds into it,
is sports rights management.
Sports are interesting
in that sometimes,
depending on the
sport, you're allowed
to see your home team
when you're away.
So if you're a New Yorker and
you're here in San Francisco--
I think with baseball,
it's called couch rights,
meaning where your couch is.
So if your couch
is in New York, you
can see anything your couch can
see, no matter where you are.
I think NFL has something
called hotel rules, where it
is wherever you physically are.
So I couldn't watch the New
York Jets, but why would I?
NEEVE NIKOO: Hey, hey--
I'm a--
GEIR MAGNUSSON:
You're a Jets fan?
NEEVE NIKOO: Yes.
Yes, sadly.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: This is
actually bigger than the talk.
We actually found a Jets fan.
NEEVE NIKOO: Yeah.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Yeah.
That's-- you know
the joke about--
it's also like the Mets.
There's a big sign in New York.
It was, welcome
to New York, home
of nine professional sports
teams, and also the Mets.
NEEVE NIKOO: Thanks, Geir.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: So one of
the things we have to do
is, where you are,
create streams
that switch based on this
rights management stuff.
And this is where we're going to
go into a little bit of depth.
When we're creating
a video stream,
it's actually a
personalized stream for you.
Every time the player is
asking for that manifest,
we're not just serving it
something out of a CDN.
What we're doing
is a rights check.
We know who you are.
And then we, based on
switching information
that we have on the
incoming streams,
synthesize a channel
for you based
on whatever your
rights are and whatever
you're supposed to see.
So every four seconds, we
do a computation for you.
We get what the manifests
are for whatever
streams could be contributing
to what your channel is.
And then we write out a
manifest specifically for you
and return that.
So that's really what
we talk about when
we say the real-time
video stream construction.
And we'll go into
that in some depth.
We have to manage DVRs.
That's a talk unto itself.
The rights metadata is
what I was referring to.
It's how we construct
these streams.
Encoding and storage-- we do
some delivery optimization.
What we can do is, because--
as we're writing
this manifest, we
have the option of choosing
where you get the segment from.
So if Google CDN is
the most responsive
where you are at
that moment, we might
write the URLs to pull the
segments out of Google CDN.
But if you were--
maybe Fastly was better for you.
We then use Fastly.
So this gives us the ability
to optimize the consumer
experience to go for the
lowest latency possible.
It also gives us the ability
to easily steer around a CDN
when there's a failure.
And like everything
else, they fail.
Program, data and disc--
program, comma, data,
and discovery--
we do a lot in search
and personalization.
It's something that we've
been really focused on,
and it's really the area
of main focus for us
in the consumer
experience going forward.
We get this metadata,
schedule metadata,
and we have to process it,
normalize it, and then make
it available to the front ends
as well as internal systems
for channel construction.
And then subscriber data
and user management--
we're a subscription
business direct to consumer.
We have to take credit cards.
We have to do billing.
We use Recurly for that.
But that's that section.
NEEVE NIKOO: And
the only thing I'll
add is, when I was talking
about all the different partners
and components--
if you look at this slide and
just the number of people,
the number of companies
that are needed,
this just puts it
in perspective,
on that slide that I showed, how
much actually goes into this.
And we're going to go
into technical depth
on certain components,
but this, I think,
puts into perspective
how tough this is
and how many moving
parts there are.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: And it gets
worse when you add advertising.
NEEVE NIKOO: Yeah.
GEIR MAGNUSSON:
Because at this point,
you're producing video
stream, and then you've
got to put a layer
of advertising
to personalize each stream.
So we use GCP stuff.
We're at a Google conference.
We are primarily Google
Cloud and always have been.
NEEVE NIKOO: It's the wizard.
It's the magical wizard.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: I
thought it was the--
I thought they were just
trying to move us along here.
I'm kind of averse, personally,
to the more advanced
proprietary offerings
that you find in the cloud
provider, honestly.
So fundamentally, we're
there for the compute network
and storage, which
we find is excellent.
It's really good stuff.
We do use Kubernetes.
I think no talk here would
be complete without somebody
mentioning Kubernetes.
We do use BigQuery.
That is one of those
proprietary technologies
that we made the
decision to go with.
It's excellent.
It is the core engine
behind everything
we do with search
personalization, metrics,
analytics.
We use Cloud Store for
the video segments.
We have a lot of
stories about that
because it is a general
purpose storage,
and as you can
imagine, we want to be
able to get the video
segments, as we receive them
from the encoder, to
disk as fast as possible
so we don't lose them.
But at the same
time, they have to be
available for
reading immediately
because it's a live stream.
So we're very sensitive
to the latency there.
And then we also use
Data Store, really,
for manifest and historical
manifest storage.
So I'm not going to
talk about this again.
I just wanted to,
as a reminder--
how HLS works.
What we've done is we've
taken that previous diagram
and made it a little
more complicated because
of this idea that we have
to be synthesizing channels
based on a bunch of factors.
One factor I didn't mention is--
especially, it's
important with sports--
the concept of overtime.
Nobody can predict how
long the game is really
going to go in any sport
that allows overtime.
So very often, what
we have to do--
and most people are watching--
except the things
like BN where you're
getting sports-specific
channels-- a lot of people
consume their sports on your
local affiliate, your local NBC
station here in San Francisco.
And they have a
schedule that comprises
local programming, which
might be source number one.
And then there's the
national feed, which
would be source number two.
And what we have
to do is we have
what's called SCTE signaling
information that tell us
when to switch between streams.
So you may have
local programming
up to the start of
a baseball game,
and then you switch
to the national feed
to get the baseball game.
And then you might
have to switch back
once the game is theoretically
over because then there's
"Judge Judy" or
whatever is shown.
But when you have
overtime or extended play,
like in extra innings,
this becomes a problem
because you do not want to
switch back to "Judge Judy"
when the game is
going into overtime,
because that's usually the
most exciting part of a game.
And it produces
tremendous amounts of ire
from your customers--
true hate.
Nothing is worse than,
say, dropping off
the third overtime
in a hockey game
and switching back to
the original programming.
They will come after you.
So we have these
multiple encoding
streams that we're storing.
And what's happening is this
playlist decisioning system
is using some of this metadata
to decide which source to give
you when you ask for a channel.
So in terms of a
flow, the player
is saying to an authorization
service, hey, can I watch this?
And here's my credentials.
And the auth service gives
it a token back, says, sure.
Here, give this to
the playlist service.
The player will then ask the
playlist decisioning system,
give me my manifest
for this channel.
The player decisioning
system will,
based on where you
are in time and what's
supposed to be happening,
choose the source stream
and provide a manifest
to you that tells you
what the segments are next.
It can also rewrite
the URLs to get them.
So we can choose
among a set of CDNs
that we work with, which CDN
is going to deliver to you.
And then the player says, all
right, give me the segment,
to the right CDN.
The CDN then gets
it from origin.
It's not that
interesting, that part.
And then lather,
rinse, and repeat--
you ask for your next manifest.
The playlist decisioning system
can choose a different stream
based on whatever really
you're supposed to see,
and then you may choose even a
different CDN because something
happened with the first
CDN that you were using.
So this is really how
we produce streams.
And if you think
about it, it means
that every single stream
that we produce is unique.
They're going to look the same,
but they are, in theory, unique
because we are computing
them specifically
for a given player.
Now, this is a business
where we take all the money
that the consumers
give us, and then
we take some other
money that we get
from either advertising
or VCs, and we give it
all to the content owners.
This is not in itself a
sustainable business model.
It's a very difficult business.
So where the
financials come in is--
really, advertising is the core
monetization for the company.
And it, too, is an
interesting technical problem.
I used to be the
CTO of AppNexus.
When I left AppNexus,
I thought, OK, I've
done on my time in advertising.
I will never go back to this.
And I find now that,
really, most of my attention
is being spent on advertising.
NEEVE NIKOO: And Google knows
nothing about advertising.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Sorry?
NEEVE NIKOO: We don't know
anything about advertising.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Right.
Yeah, don't ask about that
division of the company.
We're here to talk about Cloud.
NEEVE NIKOO: Right, right.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: As we
said, every video stream
is unique and independent.
And that gives us the
ability to produce
advertising that is unique
and independent for each user.
This is the holy
grail for advertisers,
is to be able to target
you specifically.
And it's going to be
watched, unlike like, say,
web display, where most of
it is below the fold anyway.
This is something--
your TV is up there.
And this is not a distracting
thing in the corner.
I'm not going to apologize.
That's how television works.
But at some point, you
go to commercial break
and the commercials are shown.
So these are ads that are shown.
There are humans
that watch them.
So we can determine
in real time.
And this is not a new
concept for anybody
that has been doing
advertising the last 10 years.
But for television,
it's kind of a new idea.
And honestly, the
television buyers,
the people who are buying
advertising for television,
don't get it yet.
They don't really
understand that we can
target to the individual user.
So how does it
work, technically?
So if you remember
what we talked
about before-- the player
talks to the playlist service,
which gets manifests
and the cycle continues.
What we do is we put an
ad stitcher in front.
And what an ad stitcher
looks like-- it's just
a proxy in some ways.
And when the player
asks for a manifest,
the ad stitcher goes to
the playlist service,
and the manifest is
produced, and it's returned.
Now, as it's coming back--
to get an advertisement,
there are queue points.
There might be a little line
in the manifest that says,
queue out here.
And you can do it
for 60 seconds.
That's a 60 second ad break.
Now, there still is going
to be video segments listed.
Those are the video segments
on the original stream.
So that would actually
be the advertisement
that the content owners, say,
CNN, has on their channel.
But as part of the agreement we
have with the content owners,
they give us some amount of
time per hour, say, one to two
minutes, two to three minutes.
So when we get our ad
break, what will happen then
is MediaTailor will
look at the manifest,
the ad stitcher,
looks at the manifest,
sees that an ad break is coming,
and then it makes an ad call.
And it calls-- we have
a proxy because we
wanted to be able to have some
control over in real time.
We were calling
which ad server we
want to work with and logging
and all sorts of stuff.
It's obviously a
good idea to do.
And what we do is we choose
among a set of ad servers or ad
partners.
FreeWheel, you've
probably heard of.
It is owned by Comcast.
It's a very popular,
very big video ad server.
SpringServe is a lesser known
but an excellent ad server.
APS is Amazon's
publishing system.
They do buying.
And then the ad servers
talk to, basically,
SSPs or other demand partners
who figure out who has an ad
and wants that specific
person or that specific device
or whatever.
Then the ad slot is filled
up with ads, basically,
links to ads.
And that whole pile is then
sent back up to MediaTailor,
to the ad stitcher.
Now, these are MP4s.
They can't actually be
inserted in an HLS stream
because HLS has multiple
variants at different bit
rates.
What the ad stitcher
has to do is
take the advertisements
that came back from the ad
decisioning side of things.
It has to transcode them.
It has to turn them into
the same variant rates
that we have the
main streams on,
which means that,
for the first time
it ever sees an
advertisement, it
can't show it because
it hasn't transcoded it.
You can't transcode
them that fast.
So it transcodes them,
puts it into a CDN,
and remembers that it
has transcoded that ad
so the next time that ad comes
through, which it will, the ad
is ready to play.
And it rewrites the
manifest so that instead
of getting the video
chunks that are
from the underlying
streams, CNN,
it actually then just
gives video chunks
that are advertising chunks.
So it's a seamless process.
The player generally doesn't
know what's going on.
There's some variance to that.
Sometimes the player can
do beaconing as well.
But fundamentally, from
a playback perspective,
the player has no idea.
It's just getting video segment,
video segment, video segment.
Video segments happen to switch
from original content video
segment to advertising segment.
And then when
there's a queue in,
basically, it's where the
playlist service is saying,
all right, ad break is over.
You've got to go
back to content.
Then MediaTailor
stops doing anything
and just keeps them
flowing through.
And that's really how
server-side ad stitching works.
Fairly simple in
theory, but a lot
of moving parts, a lot of
things that can go wrong.
If any of you have worked
with advertising technologies,
they can be a mess.
And these are.
So I think that was it in
terms of the overall tech
part of things.
NEEVE NIKOO: Yeah, and I
guess the only thing I'll say
is all of that that
he just explained
happens in between when you--
literally, the game is on
and then goes to halftime.
That little blip,
all of that literally
happens in the backend just
to serve you the correct ad.
So it's a very,
very quick process
that needs to happen in
order to stitch all of that
together to serve you
that advertisement.
So I hope-- I don't
know if it's just me.
It's a really,
really hard problem
that happens super, super fast.
He explained that
over 5, 10 minutes,
and that happens in
[SNAPS] Like that.
So it's just to put
it in perspective,
all of the moving
pieces to do that.
Sorry.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: So in
terms of best practices,
we've been on this journey
for a couple of years.
We didn't do what
people normally do,
which is do on prem so they
can control everything.
As you imagine, we're
really sensitive to network.
We're really
sensitive to compute.
We're really sensitive
to storage latency.
But we did it all
on the Cloud, and I
guess we have some best
practices that we've learned.
And I'll say together,
because honestly, Google--
when you're working with a
cloud provider like this,
they are your operations team,
or part of your operations
team, whether you
realize it or not.
And our relationship is to
the point where it really
is a partnership.
That's really the
last point here.
They're not just a vendor.
You shouldn't treat
them like a vendor
if it's something
core to your business.
And they shouldn't treat
you like a customer or just
a customer.
You need to be part
of the same team.
We have weekly calls
that they participate
with us and with
other third parties
that we work with because
we're so sensitive to things
like network.
Their networking
team is on the call.
It is not just the usual
front-facing customer
engineers.
We can get deep into
their teams because they
have a vested interest
in us succeeding.
Other ideas is that, look,
these cloud systems are
built for general purpose use.
They're not built for us.
They're built for
thousands of customers,
multi-tenancy, a wide
range of workloads.
So test your use case.
It's kind of obvious.
We're very sensitive to latency.
And we have to
design around some
of the uncertainty in
latency that we see
in these cloud-based systems.
Cloud systems behaviors are
subject to change, sometimes
just due to failure, but
that's not that interesting
because everything fails.
Sometimes it feels like
the systems actually
change their behavioral
properties based on load.
Normally, we have no problem
with hotkeys in a data store,
and all of a sudden keys become
hotkeys and latency increases
or fail.
These are things you just have
to be aware of will happen,
and it's due to other
activities within the Cloud
because these are
shared systems.
And then this idea for
proprietary technology--
choose carefully, because what
is a quick win today-- like,
oh, let me just use
that because it's quick,
and I can get the system up--
is next year's tech debt.
And it's sometimes awfully hard
to back out of these things.
We made a decision to go with
BigQuery, very happy with it.
It is a proprietary
lock-in kind of thing.
We are kind of stuck.
We're not unhappy.
We don't want to go.
But if you think
about what it would
take to move all of
this data out of Google
into somewhere else,
it's not a problem
I even want to think about.
I think that-- do you have
anything you want to add on--
NEEVE NIKOO: I think, just
to bring the point home--
we have these weekly calls.
What is that weekly call?
There's going to be many
different people that
are all always involved.
All those partners that you
saw will have multiple calls
with different partners.
And it's just really being aware
of the different services that
are segmented and who's
all involved and where.
An I think just being an
honest, open, transparent--
not to be cliché, but DevOpsian
culture and environment really
helped, I think, make
us successful together,
because we understand that
there's all these moving pieces
and all these different parts
and partners that are involved.
And it's just about,
together, solving this problem
and understanding
where each piece fits.
And I think it really,
really helped us really
both be successful.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Yeah.
NEEVE NIKOO: And
move really fast.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: I think there
are Google engineers that
spend more time talking with
some of our technical partners
than I do.
NEEVE NIKOO: Yeah.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: It's true.
And I think it's great
because they are world class
experts in the things
they're working on,
and they can really get
to the root of a problem
when there is one.
And there are problems.
NEEVE NIKOO: Yeah.
GEIR MAGNUSSON:
There always will be.
Our future, we're trying
to bring key core services
in-house.
We'll continue to build more new
things on the Google platform.
Multi-cloud-- it's amazing that
the marketing people let this
through.
But it's one of the
things we're doing,
mainly driven by
external forces.
There are content streams that
are coming into other cloud
environments, not to Google.
And we have to go
over there to be
able to receive them
and encode them,
and then we can
bring things over.
We're going to continue
investing in personalization,
more markets, not just Spain,
and then apparently there's
something I know
that he doesn't which
we're going to put up here--
NEEVE NIKOO: Anything exciting?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: I'm
not going to tell.
NEEVE NIKOO: All right.
We'll have to wait and see.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: That's it.
NEEVE NIKOO: That's it.
We left a little less than 10
minutes, 8 minutes it says,
for any questions
that you might have.
If you could do the feedback,
we really appreciate it.
I think it's really important
so we can make sure if there's
anything to fix, change.
We love honest feedback.
If you have any questions,
the mics are there.
Line up.
We'll be here.
About seven, eight minutes left,
so we appreciate your time.
AUDIENCE: I got one
question on DVR.
How are you dealing with
massive parallel DVR recording?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Lots of storage.
It's a big expense,
but we have the--
think about what a DVR
recording is in the cloud.
We have all the segments.
They land because where we're
taking them off the encoders
and putting them in.
The DVR process happens in the
background and makes copies.
That's really how it works.
And it's a large
storage cost for us.
We use different tiers of
storage for this purpose,
because unlike the first line
of storage for the CDN origins,
which have to be fast--
wish they were faster--
DVR doesn't have to be as fast.
You can accept some latency.
When somebody hits
play on a DVR,
it can be pulled out
of the nearline storage
and start playing.
AUDIENCE: Google has
an Anvato service that
checks a lot of the same boxes.
Why not use them instead?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: They
have a suite of services.
They have an encoding service.
I think have an ad stitcher.
They don't do what we do.
They don't have the
rights management.
They don't handle
the things that we
needed to do to be able
to license this content
and distribute it.
These kind of
services, like Anvato,
they were pointed out
on the original slide
by content owners.
If I'm NBC, I know exactly
what I'm going to do
and don't have to worry about
licensing in the same way we
do because they are the ones
that are putting the licensing
constraints on us.
So I think it's a good
set of building blocks.
We had to do something
different, fundamentally,
with playlist generation.
And then honestly,
given how sensitive
we are to a good
video experience,
we are trying to do
more and more things
like encoding in-house.
So at least if something
goes wrong, it's our fault,
and it's something
that we can fix.
If it's a third-party
provider, there's
not a lot you can do sometimes.
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify a
couple of icons on the slide,
I'm guessing that you use GCS
for video segment data storage.
But I was curious what you use
for the video stream metadata
storage, if that's GCS
or if it's faster or--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: You mean--
AUDIENCE: --different
in any way?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: The manifests?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the manifests.
Yeah.
GEIR MAGNUSSON:
So the manifests,
they go in a data store
right now because we
need them time-ordered.
We are switching to a
different system which, again,
preserves that time order.
We think it's going to be a--
basically, if you think about--
Kafka is a time-ordered
list of stuff
that is permanent until
you roll it off the back.
That solves that problem as
well, so we do it that way.
AUDIENCE: So switching
to Kafka, then?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: We are
testing a solution that is
based on a large Kafka cluster.
It's a flat load input
because you've got
800 channels or 1,000 channels.
They have a completely
predictable and stable load.
So that's actually easy
to ingest in store,
and the variable load
is on the output.
So how many people, concurrent
streams, are coming in?
And it's an easy problem
for something like Kafka
because you confront it with a
cache in front that keeps, say,
the last 15 minutes of
manifests in memory.
And if everybody's watching
the exact same program,
it's not a problem.
You're just pulling it around.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: How did you get
a server-side connection
to DFP to do your ad
stitching for your proxy?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Sorry
I missed the question.
Say it again?
AUDIENCE: What
did you have to do
to get a server-side
connection to DFP
to include their ads in your
stitching on your server's
side.
GEIR MAGNUSSON: What
happens is the ad stitcher
makes the ad call to us.
It goes to an ad server, just
a conventional video ad server.
And that makes the call
to something like DFP.
So that might be
somebody is buying Roku.
They really want to
buy Roku impressions.
They give us tags that
come from DFP's ad server.
Our ad server will call
that just to see, hey,
do you want this?
And it'll return
either a VAST or not.
That all gets packaged
together and returned.
So it's not like there's a
connection between the ad
stitcher and the demand
partners directly.
The ad server is making the
calls to the demand partners
and going back.
We don't use DFP
as our ad server.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Are you currently
using or have plans
to use any machine learning
services for content
delivery or ad delivery?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: We're
experimenting on both of those.
It's primarily in the area of
recommendation and similar.
But there are some
interesting uses
for detection of advertisement,
detection of sentiment,
to understand what's
happening in a game.
If we could
automatically know a game
is going into overtime by
understanding what the game
action is, or the clock,
or the scoreboard,
it would make our
lives a lot simpler,
although it's a fairly
sophisticated way
to do it versus just having
somebody watch it and hit
a button.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
If you have a critical
failure in the ad pipeline,
what does the experience
look like for the customer?
Do you try and fail
in favor of them or--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Sorry,
in which pipeline?
AUDIENCE: So this whole
ad pipeline, here,
the thing that delivers
the adverts to the customer
in some kind of break--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --if they saw some
kind of critical failure,
and you can't deliver those ads,
what does the experience look
like for the customer?
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Ah.
This is actually the best
failure mode we have.
Because, if you remember--
say you're watching CNN.
CNN goes into an ad break.
There are CNN ads there.
CNN is putting
advertising there.
It's the same stream
you get on TV.
So if there's a failure
to deliver, to get
an advertisement, or to
transcode the advertisement,
then just the underlying
stream just plays
and the user has no
idea something happened.
That's assuming the
ad stitcher doesn't
do something really stupid.
But it generally doesn't.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Is your ad stitcher having
to decode and reencode
so that it can--
GEIR MAGNUSSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
So when an advertisement
is first seen--
so suppose it's a 30 second
ad for Ford something.
I don't know.
It has a unique identifier,
usually just the URL for it,
for the MP4.
MediaTailor keeps a list
of all the advertisements
that it knows about
and has encoded.
And if it's not on that list,
it will run a transcode process
in the same way we transcode
the incoming stream,
turn it into the
bit rate variance
that we're using
so that it can be
slotted right into whatever
bit rate stream the player
is playing.
That means, of course, that
the first time an ad is seen
by the ad stitcher, it
cannot be played to the user.
And that's a case where
there is that failure mode.
We just don't show an ad and the
underlying stream is playing.
I should have drawn it.
I'm sorry.
There should've been
a little loop here
saying this is where
the encoding happens.
But then once it
has it, it's cached.
It can serve that ad
next time the decisioning
system says, show that ad.
[MUSIC PLAYING]